now for spring and summer people are
wondering how to get fit fast I know I
am so Doug Zuko owner of fastfit the
sponsor of this segment is here with the
solution I can't wait to hear this we do
I cannot wait so Doug introduce
everybody to fastfit what's your method
what's your what's your mission here
fastfit has a patent-pending fat loss
system that helps people lose pounds of
fat and you know of course we think
we're gonna diet right that we're going
to lose fat but that's not necessarily
true when we lose weight most of the
time we're not losing fat man because
you the depending on how hard you work
you can work out really hard and still
have those trouble areas areas
absolutely but even when people just die
right yeah people don't work out they
lose weight
but they don't lose fat they lose muscle
mass they lose hydration it always comes
back well please explain please explain
I hear the term is visceral fat that's
what we're we're not able to combat here
absolutely so basically we have an
illustration I think but basically we
have two types of fat in our body right
so the outside jiggly fat that we can
pinch that's subcutaneous fat that means
it's under the skin and then we have the
deadly visceral fat that we don't really
know about it's under the muscle so you
can't grab it okay but it's the
dangerous fact it gives off all the
inflammation produces so much of the
harmful estrogen that robs the body of
energy it's the bad stuff that we don't
want wow so how do you how do you combat
that what are you gonna do right around
age 35 the body changes and we're not
able to even really burn visceral fat
anymore so at fast fits system it
targets not only subcutaneous fat but
visceral fat one of the only systems
that can do that all the other
procedures can only do subcutaneously
but because we don't kill any fat cells
because we're healthy and safe we can
get rid of this stuff oh okay bye-bye
and after with Patricia explain what's
happening with her body well look at the
difference of Patricia Patricia lost 57
pounds of pure fat 81 pounds overall but
look at her skin no sags or wrinkles
she's it looks like she's 20 years old
around 30 years old incredible okay next
is Vera
and Vera basically you know just a very
petite person we're seeing her now
that's only five and a half pounds of
fat gone so this is five pounds of
patches five and a half pounds of fat
going Begin Again look at her skin
quality okay let's look at Jose let's
let's get a man's body there's a man's
body right Jose's 53 years old just
totally ripped doesn't do any workouts
just came to fast fit what okay now I
know you're listening now okay next one
last is Ron here rolling 65 years old
you know he used to be in shape when he
was very young he got it back his abs
were hiding there the whole time he
didn't know what look at that okay well
thank you Doug for that because I know a
lot of you guys are interested in
getting fit and being your best self so
fast Fit Body Sculpting you can call
1-800 fast fit the website it's fast dot
fit
um and your special offer is up to 60
off for the first 20 callers
call Doug now we'll be right back